vegetarisch versus Fleisch essen die
Kontroverse auf dem Land tretboy stoßen
ich komme eher aus dem urbanenraum und
ich würde behaupten wir haben eindeutig
zu wenig Bezug zu den Fleischproduzenten
bauen ich glaube aber auch dass die
fehlenden Berührungspunkte zu den
ländlichen Regionen über das Fleisch
essen hinausgehen und ein großes Problem
darstellen in der Schweiz andere
Kommentare die gleiche richtig vom Simon
Schmid 320 ich denke wir am Schluss
gesagt wurde viel zu viele Menschen
haben in der heutigen Zeit den Bezug zur
Landwirtschaft allgemein verloren und
wissen nicht oder gar nichts darüber was
schwer bedenklich ist ja beim Thema
vegetarisch wäre das Fleisch essen geht
es wirklich statt Landgraben also auf
der Stadt in der Stadt wird zum Beispiel
mehr Produkten
Erklärvideos machen
persönliche Mini persönliche Meinung zu
dem Thema ist einfach das mit samarett
einfach verliert
787 da schreibt ich bin eigentlich sehr
locker eingestellt gegenüber Vegetarier
und Veganer nur das einzige was mich
nervt sind diese dummen Sprüche die man
sich gegenseitig an den Kopf wirft ist
es denn wirklich nötig deswegen einander
fertig zu machen statt die
Entscheidungen des anderen zu
respektieren hey da bin ich voll bei dir
also gegen respekt das ist wirklich
nie vergessen danke für die Kommentare
das Miteinander akzeptieren
ich finde es etwas irritierend dass man
einen Milchbauern fragt wieso er nicht
mehr vegetarische Produkte produziert
die Kälber sind leider ein Nebenprodukt
der Milchindustrie es handelte sich hier
nicht in erster Linie um einen Mast
sondern um einen Milchbetrieb das wurde
in der Doku leider nicht verwandt ich
gebe dir recht das ist wirklich
Niederland hat die USA erwartet
Steffen
das stimmt und er könnte oder Fläche hat
gar nicht einfach von Landwirtschaft
Arbeit
Kommentator wird Politik ins Thema
vegetarisch wäre das Fleisch essen
initiiert zum Beispiel der epic Sun
Storm mit der Reportage kann ich mich
als vegetarische Bauerntochter vom Dorf
sehr gut identifizieren die
Landwirtschaftspolitik muss den
inländischen Markt so schützen dass der
Anbau von
getreidehülsenfrüchten Kartoffeln und so
weiter kostendeckend und lohnenswert ist
der Import von Fleisch welches nicht den
hiesigen Tierschutzbestimmungen
entspricht sollte untersagt werden es
sind schon zwei verschiedene Welten
statt und Land wenn man vergisst
hey hier geht's schon politische
bestrafungenstrategie 2050
hauptsächlich für die direkt die
Produktion von menschlicher Ernährung
in Zukunft werden subventionieren
zum ersten
Kommentar das ist es Kompliment vom
Martin Wüthrich 384
über solche wunderbare Geschäfte wie
diese Familienbetrieb sollte man sich
freuen hier werden die Tiere sehr gut
behandelt und ganz kurz und schnell
getötet lassen wir doch deshalb die
vernünftigen und beispielhaften und
guten Betriebe in Ruhe
das freut mich natürlich
der Transportwagen und alles zusammen
passiert
danke für die Objektive Reportage ich
esse zwar ab und zu Fleisch habe aber in
den letzten Jahren vermehrt den Zugang
zur ausgewogenen Küche ohne
fleischzusatz gefunden diese Beitrag
beweist dass das Umdenken zu Gunsten
eines bewussten Fleischkonsums bereits
begonnen hat wir lebst
ja danke
[Musik]
günstig kommen sofort bewusste
Fleischkonsum vom vato 99
reduziert zu Hause gar kein Fleisch
auswärts nur zu besonderen Anlassen oder
wenn ich Lust dazu habe was ich damit
sagen möchte wir würden in Bezug aufs
Klima und den nachhaltigen Umgang in der
Landwirtschaft schon viel erreichen wenn
wir unseren Konsum pro Kopf von 50 Kilo
pro Jahr reduzieren es müssen nicht alle
VegetarierInnen werden aber bewussten
Konsum zu reduzieren würde fürs Klima
und das Tierwohl auch schon helfen ja
das ist jetzt schon Sachen
wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
Produkte meines ist irgendwie auf der
Straße und zum Thema
irgendwo kaufen
das funktioniert eigentlich
es gibt eigentlich kein Argument mehr
für das Fleisch essen ich selber essen
Fleisch einfach weil ich zu faul und zu
egoistisch bin um damit aufzuhören ich
weiß dass es nicht gut ist mache es aber
trotzdem aber das ist nicht gut ist für
Tier- und Umwelt ist mir bewusst und
jeder Fleischesser würde das selber
sagen
Michael
sehr gerne
[Musik]
persönlich
immer wenig denkst du jeder
nee das überhaupt
relativ offen für Fragen
wie funktioniert das nicht irgendwie
gefühlt genau und danke
Objektiv oder Darstellung läuft und wie
wie mobil
genau der
hinten
auch die Seite auf dem Land mich würde
interessieren wie viel Fleisch nicht
konsumiert wird das ist für mich viel
schlimmer wenn ein Kalb oder Lamm
geschlachtet wird und außerdem viele der
Rest im Müll landet landet bei euch
zurück im Köder es geht natürlich
nach dem Grund bringt
was davon
um der Tierwelt Download für Kosmetiker
und bin froh dass über ein solches Thema
gesprochen wird nun wollte ich fragen
was du von der vergangenen Ernährung
hältst da in der Milch und ei-industrie
auch viele viele Tiere leiden und
getötet werden oder der Super Mario
55,88 Vegetarier sind mit ihrem Milch
und Ei Konsum Komplizen der
Fleischwirtschaft wird hier leider
wirklich minimieren will verzichtet auf
alle tierischen Produkte hey spannen die
Punkte natürlich das Thema
kräftige du jetzt nach dem Besuch bei
der mich Hunger
konsumiere sehr wenige Milchprodukten
als Trainer dort habe ich als Vegetarier
fast immer zwei ministerauswahl Pommes
mit Ketchup und Pommes mit Maja
Messi abonnieren
[Musik]